hey welcome to this week's Android
developer office hours I'm joined here
in London by Matt Chris Bane's Nick
butcher
and I'm rich Hyndman which I should have
said up front we've already got his
David and vibha joined us in the Hangout
hi guys hi hey
as usual we'll be discussing Android
development topics and also as usual we
won't be discussing roadmaps few things
unreleased
what unannounced I guess perhaps I said
thank you for all the questions in the
moderator this week we do have one so
maybe we'll just get the two I see we'll
get those out of the way up front and
then just go into some kind of
discussion and hopefully some more
people would join us and keep the
content going throughout okay what was
our one moderator question we had why
was the u.s. office I was Scott back
well has it been stopped yes thanks the
US team played with the office hours
full map for a while and they decided to
move on to other formats like this week
in Android maybe there's a time zone
thing but they weren't getting too many
viewers I see lots of people all come
into this time slot it's funny we do we
used to call this Android developer
office hours EMEA maybe we still do but
um looking at the statistics on YouTube
the viewers are actually from the US so
maybe it's just in the morning and I'm
in North Carolina yeah I have a question
Chris we discussed last time you can use
Wi-Fi direct yeah as a way of
do you know a what's the impact for the
mobile battery or the device you trying
to pair
I don't off top my head I haven't used
the API emerged myself so I can't
comment on battery life and lock on
stuff I don't know I imagine it's better
than backbone bluetooth but it'll be
guessing nice got any experience by
direct I mean I have Wi-Fi on the whole
time on my device right we need to dr.
power turn on Wi-Fi direct and see if
he's as much battery life I tell you
what I'll make her moan at this question
I imagine it's better just with the
sheer mass boundary if you have say the
radio can go to sleep quicker with
Bluetooth limited to 100 care second
whereas Wi-Fi direct but that's against
I don't you say the betting CDs prepaid
market yeah okay what use me for fever I
was looking for a way to connect my
Google TV with my tablet and my
telephone but I can't use it for my
Google TV because it's 4.1 and up yeah
but I try to connect might and my
telephone with my tablet to see what is
doing maybe GCM oh that's good yeah and
there goes the weekend again I'm trying
I'm using mobile and I'm looking into
what's the other framework called will
join but they're really terrible all
join space be quite stable but of well
they looks quite good
the website well that's what codes like
good the Javadoc and the implementation
examples are really terrible so a basic
application is a lot of work to do
interesting okay thank you David
well no I was trying to look at I was
just watching another show last night
and they were talking this this
application would allow you to share
bandwidth across all your devices I'm
trying to remember the name of it now
and I can't remember now it'll connect
them all together well they used to use
Wi-Fi direct and they stopped that
option it's only bluetooth now so I
think they were it might be something to
do you have the link for the the video
find it it was I was on another show and
I don't want to like you know give
avatar and all that but my watch me I'm
all about Android they were talking
about it so yeah yeah it was on a show
about the Android only but it was all
about Android and they were showing it
now but it's only bluetooth and if I
find it I'll I'll send it up okay great
right
hey that's high road as well welcome to
the Hangout Javan up any questions for
us today
well I think you might be muted there I
can't hear you yeah no hello hi we go
hey hey hey guys uh no questions I'm
just kind of listening and see if I can
pick up some pointers and stuff nice
okay marty is also just joining us say
there Marty looks like you must be on a
phone Nexus 4 Nexus 7 yeah I'll just be
listening in okay hey are you the same
Marty who's just asked a question in the
moderator yep that's me you want to go
ahead and ask it on video
sure I was just asking it the
photosphere is open sourced and if it is
is there an example somewhere that can
review question all right doubt that
photosphere is open source yet we have
some API is now which allow you to check
your images our photo spheres and that
sort of thing and playback photo spheres
but I don't believe the photo sphere
itself is open source now is there some
examples for how to use those ABS part
of the Google Play services library
there yeah for how to check if it's been
launched the fittest
okay great google.com slash Android and
and the Google Play services is in there
you know check Google Play services if
you've got the support library on your
download into your SDK will be on your
your filing system already on your on
your PC under 94 thank you extras any
other live questions in the room before
we hi guys no nothing later on I'll come
up with something we'll be able to reply
to comments on place on Google Play if
so is there any estimated date so I
guess this would fall and the you know
top the show that we're not going to
comment about roadmap and stuff like
even if we did know a day when there's
the Royal to everyone then it was
probably changing so I think the
intentions to this run out to everyone
it hasn't happened
we've been expanding the trial group
versus ignite it will happen yeah yeah
I'd love to be able to just every I
would sure love to be able to just least
talk to people that call me names to see
why they really are having problems with
my apps yeah as they getting getting the
saying oh this is not appropriate you
know has the Google+ identity stuff help
to toll you be able to reach out to them
directly if I that know I see like they
say they're a Google user but I don't
hire all the ones that user are historic
all new reviews that go in as of about a
month ago have to have a Google+
identity associated with them so you
will be able to reach them and at least
find them on Google+ and speak backs
then that way if you want the previous
good news ones if you search by date
entered instead of by relevance then
you'll see that the top ones should all
have an ID next to them most have the
ones that people have taped this was
useful to me filter to the top in
relevance but yeah interesting to see
so thanks the question Evelyn and sorry
we can't really commit two days and
stuff for that but is it possible to
publish an apk internally within a
company and not through the Play Store
okay yeah the first part I think is
Vives that as well the answer was yes is
it possible to publish an apk internally
within a company yes and you can do that
inside the Play Store if you're using a
Google Apps domain you get your own
little your own domain square inside the
application section of the Play Store
and you can have all your employees
access those applications so that's
great but then it goes on to say not
Facebook which is strange and then it
goes on to say that using the Google
Maps API so is the Google Maps API
linked to publishing through the Play
Store
once the device has got these Google
experience without Google Maps should
work if only things that are linked to
publishing through the Play Store are
the things that use the market the place
to apply and which would be lvl in-app
billing
yeah the subscriptions expansion files
yeah it's nice and fast thank you that
video yeah BB's that's probably and the
rest of the API is that you get
available to you via the API console our
Google API is as opposed to Android API
so I'll play the ice and you can access
all of those for your application most
of them will have certain amounts of
free quota and then you can either ask
for more or go into paid quota Google
services so yes you can use you've
mapped as long as the device you are
distributing it on has coconut so next
question software bloke from there
Malone has asked if I add a birth dates
my contracts will be great if the date
would sing with G condor and set
notifications for love it it actually
already does that
so when you set your birth date if
you've gone to Google Calendar on the
web you can add a calendar called
contact birthdays many awesome as he
shows you calendar it doesn't do good
staff Chris okay so Andre in Prague
asks if subscriptions are going to be
part of their be free bidding API and at
least a time frame so again see the top
of the show we know do we acquit is it
if we definitely said it's gonna be
plugging I think everything is going to
the new infrastructure
yes yeah it says inside the
documentation that it will someone
called the kondal in Italy I made my
first stack for a university course and
my professor said it's good but on
samsung device it runs well and on HTC's
it doesn't is there a good way to test
my help on different devices emulators
and yeah I mean I think what you trying
to say is that it's a some reason is his
app doesn't work on Samsung was it it
works and Samsung was a few things
Samsung online tests to do that you can
use if you become a Samsung developer
it's free for the first X number of
tests so go to Samsung developer and
look for a remote device access and then
you can check out devices you can say I
want a note 2 on phone where X and 1
it's available you get to just go into
your web browser upload your apk and
test it for free so for Samsung's it's
not too bad I don't know if any of the
other Android OEMs that provide that
service sony has a system again a
cloud-based service there are a number
of them out there they don't charge for
their services
calabash testdroid device anywhere and
there's a budget that's Troy device
anyway yeah these things so go to those
websites have a look use a popular
search engine to find them and you
should yeah be able to find good ways of
eBay uploading a test script and having
it run across a number of hardware
devices and then you receive back the
log damps the screenshot all that kind
of thing interesting why he thinks it's
a Samsung HTC issue in my experience
like a comparing similar devices quest
manufacturers isn't really the issue for
like performance wise it might be you
know comparing and galaxy s free to you
know HTC Wildfire remem there's are two
very very different respects and price
devices though I'd be interested in some
more details of what the different
questions were and also you don't
mention we're further
say my API levels so ever you're running
on Ice Cream Sandwich versus jellybean
or whatever like more like rehydrate
acceleration and hardware acceleration
for example yes a gingerbread versus
jellybean for example take a look at
your stats in the developer console as
well you'll be able to see what
percentage of your installs are on each
of the API levels and later on each
device that kind of thing it might help
you break it down and find out where the
issues are another good way and we'll
going low-tech illnesses and if you join
you local Android user group this is
certainly a way we seen before it's good
way to meet with other Android
developers talk Android chat but also
you know to do a beater with them say
hey can you guys furnace and get like a
you know the cross-section of devices
and tell me what what's going on and you
get like you know some informed people
giving you feedback on and then to
performances that I probably give you
tips but I think you've been wrong in
your code as well yeah
free coffee at all costs because testing
you out to a wide variety of handsets is
really distributed that Julian is just
joining us Don Vito as a memory yes yep
does anybody else who's just joined us
or anybody else in the in the Hangout
have a question for us is Amit in hang
out he was in left he's also done is
done oh it's that Nick do you ask you a
question oh you don't have a microphone
you can copy and paste it in from the
moderator
let's watch him type yeah we could just
stop relevant so this is the cursor
other than the Android development
question yeah other than Android
development
yeah he's posted a bit yes for this verb
no for this interesting
let's go three down other than
application development what are the
career opportunities in Android from the
Android Marketplace this is a question
of a lot of developers like
a shift application development
obviously split down both sides of
writing your own applications and
writing applications for other companies
tell you the two key ways and the most
reliable income always comes from
writing applications as a contractor or
consultant for other companies so that's
probably the easiest way to get into it
until you're confident enough and have
the ideas to start making your own
applications on the side as well but
there's a lot of companies set up these
days surrounding the the Play Store and
Android there's companies with their own
application stores this companies do
publishing on behalf of other
applications because a lot of developers
know how to write applications but don't
know how to publish in market though so
there's a lot of application publishing
companies and marketing company is an
advertising companies there's every
single individual part of the ecosystem
is taken care of design test side of it
yeah because you get to see toward the
process of what software development is
from a less technical sort of side so
you eat yourself into it and we ask them
how they do their testing and some say
we just outsource it and it seems to be
a pretty good solution for getting
comprehensive testing just let the
experts who do testing across multiple
devices every day do it for you
you can get into that side he's gonna
say it's just about to comment let's say
whether we've answered this question or
not whether we just totally missed the
pitch
thank you good good graphics now makes
it big good graphics for the marketplace
to be able to come up and say this is
gonna sell your app or the you know the
eye catchers or something unique like
that is a big thing that's to get a
really good design
okay apps it needs cordia's apps Nick's
been saying this for over a year now
make awesome apps I would love to have a
designer like I do my stuff for free I
would love to have someone that's more
than a design I've tried to do it but
there's only a certain amount of design
you know is you either have it or you
know I was really lucky I mean I
actually zero design skills and I
haven't gotten that look pretty bad I
put it out there and someone offered to
redesign it and never have come up with
a design as good as Maurice did for mine
today
there's two good communities you go to
on them on G+ there's the the Android
design official community and there's
another one called Android designers
which is a
invite-only but just asking them they'll
come and let you in unless you start
posting spam which Acacia get banned and
but both are very very active
communities and they have sections where
you can say here's my app any pointers
and it's all very friendly and you know
there's a section for asking work and
people to help you out with stuff so I'm
not gonna say they're going necessary
design your you're not for free but
they'll give you some pointers Android
users
you know designer who's looking for the
link to that where's that I got it
nevermind yeah excellent did you use a
book a search engine
yeah ideas one of the you know small
ones hi guys I've got that question if
you want it's a bit bit tricky one of
the requirements I've got a look into is
to do with NFC card emulation mode I
know that's heavily restricted in
Android I don't know if anyone's done
anything with CyanogenMod have I've got
some open card emulation code has anyone
done anything with that at all or any
experience maybe from around the people
logged onto here as well I know you mean
okay sure but you want to emulate the an
NFC card or yes I got two low level NFC
card emulation because the there are
there aren't that expensive for I think
for a buck you can get an NFC tag oh no
it's a different mode from attacker
reading it's it's a mode it's a low
level mode be sent back and forth
messages to a device or to a door reader
yeah if you want to replace one of these
things on your phone yeah yeah okay well
thanks anyway guys
oh yes yeah yeah I've been following
that yeah he's really really good low
down low level kind of like razors how
this works I think he talks about how to
yes I need to get hold of a guy as well
yeah thank you got another question in
moderator from Alton what is the
technical problem to this deploy a
sandbox environment fitting up
yeah yeah yeah
next one back to what's available on
Android devices if you don't publish the
Play Store can you use GCM if you
haven't published through the Play Store
yeah it just needs to be on a device
that has our suite of services on it so
you still need be running on a device
that has the Play Store even if you
didn't disturb you
and you can put references to it can't
you like you have to have a dependency
yeah use his live yeah okay Sparky by
the way Sparky last week he's
transferred teens he's transitioned to
internal team at Google now hmm so you
not be joining us again he's still a
good source of Android knowledge for us
but he's not in the Android developer
relations team but he stood in the
Munich office and he still works for
Google and he's on something super cool
not which you can't say because of so I
actually posted uh in the moderator
earlier under scim about the Google Maps
API
I don't think I was clear enough for I'm
or I'm a confused a little bit is there
there is so there is a way that I can
publish an app that can only be accessed
by certain organization in the Google
Play Store I thought you said nothing
the Google Play Store my what
alright I did when I was I was confused
based on an app that only I want to
create a version of our app that only
our sales people can use it spring demo
purposes absolutely yes you can do that
okay through using a Google Apps domain
so if your company uses a Google Apps
domain to host its infrastructure in any
way your domain yeah then you say your
Domino comm then if you login to the
Android device slash Play Store yeah we
got to go to the dashboard the apps
dashboard first and turn it on okay and
then you'll get an extra square inside
in the apps section of devices that are
logged in with one of your domain
account which is just your own internal
applications okay now there was a blog
post about it just before Christmas I
believe I can figure it out for you no
it was on the Android developers blog
anyway alright I can check that yeah the
only issue I was having it's just if you
use a debug key the maps don't show up
except for on the device that you have
plugged in and then if use of production
key and try and distribute that they
behave yeah the Apple moving about the
crash when you open it up right or might
am I mistaken because I've tried to like
I've tried to use a production key and
take that apk and distribute it to some
of our salespeople
yeah oh no when they open up the app it
crashes a few regenerated the maps okay
from using your distribution it should
be fine yeah I've done that the number
of times without loading its the Play
Store and with uploading it to the Play
Store so even if you're saying if I use
a production of production API can find
the app with a production API key and
then go into the developer console and
use the production API key when you get
your your mats right API key yeah
so they're gonna collapse key is tied to
your public key store that you sign your
out with right so if you're using a
debug key the Google Maps but your
release key for your apathy won't work
we can list multiple keys certificate
next to your each API key you cover I
think so okay all right thank you but
you can do both anyway you can up your
own internal apps inside the Play Store
for people on your own domain and you
can create merit I did it using the new
maps we haven't tried it with the old
map that's me - yeah a job at the old
maps alright alright come back though
and repost in the thread if it doesn't
work for you if you find anything
getting all the ducks in a row to make
it work can be a bit stressful times get
all the dev console stuff and then the
application built properly okay I'll
figure it out
yeah you it's the link for the private
channel thank you yeah yeah me too if
nothing else coming in well we're gonna
start playing with the format of this
show as well over the next few weeks try
make the app little bit more useful for
people who are watching it afterwards
maybe form eyes which questions we'll be
answering during the show we should have
to work out what's best for you guys cuz
I know the majority of questions come in
on the day of the show like this that's
obviously okay yeah we had one question
before the show now we've got 10 items
he has been a question god
so once in for you touch this question
when we go with the GPS track one yeah
so since you have a question for in that
product not billing oh that's how you
sorry sorry I just realize how to unmute
yeah so I am it's my first time on the
hangout yeah I asked the question ages
ago and on the moderator about
preventing swiping two views on a view
pager and I took your advice Chris on
them on how on like I'm preventing that
by controlling the adapter and changing
the size ferdy's yeah so so it works for
all of all of for each page except the
first one if there's just one view
displayed and a few pager
it doesn't like show that sort of
I'm after the the feedback that you get
on the right hand side yeah that's it so
can you remind what the original
requirement was okay so my view like the
the screen that I'm trying to do is I've
got a load of
swipeable views and like that you can
only progress to to the next view once
you've completed the first few that make
sense if we trained as a wizard yeah
yeah exactly but I couldn't so I
couldn't get it to like prevent the
movement properly or I could but it was
buggy so I I tried you a method Chris
and that and that
but how do i how do i trigger it so that
it would happen when there's just one of
you in the viewpager
don't intercept any types events don't
do anything so the viewpager do it
because was yeah because if there's any
one bottom the viewpager it will they
all handle all the edge effect anyway
right but i mean i want to show the user
that they need to complete something on
the page first before so they can swipe
instead of like having like a silly like
toast that says you know you you need to
complete the the thing first in country
perform first
how can i sort of control when a defect
is shown
yeah so there's no real easy way of
doing that right sort of taking the
viewpager source into your tree and
hacking it wrong because edge effect
isn't stopped exposed to you it's
supposed to be something that's
transparent to the user and order right
ok so even if we were and we want to
change the color as well like is that
door so it's all don drawables right so
you'd have to do something right
not that remember it's all done durable
so well they're not Corinth but other
thinkin okay
as a quick theme Roman Nurik is their
replacements or releases T's wizard wit
suppose the wizard pager yeah I have a
look at that and that's a really good
example of how to do this nicely okay so
have a look at and see how he's done it
okay thanks a lot guys Cheers okay let's
grab that one out of the cheapest
treatment yep so in-app billing for
offline functionality how can I make
sure that unit has access for some
function on my hat if this functionality
is dependent on in-app billing sorry so
essentially if they want to charge for a
certain aspect of an app but the user
isn't online how can you still say
he charged them and give them access to
it if they're not online yeah well you
can't charge with an online and your app
should clearly cache whether or not it's
been purchased or not well yes they
restore trans actually isn't it all cash
if you're not online no no we have the
cash to play store
yes I've using the V for the you not
billion Nano it's all cash then you wait
for you so there's no need to cash of a
Salesman
oh it's pens which will call your
transaction so imagine just trying to
send to the store the transaction didn't
take it off in advance in the future
things you can't force the user if you
want to kick it off get in the future
you can't force them to actually go
through of it yeah
so you give it them for free so yeah all
depends on your business model but oh
you've probably wanted to wait till I go
back online before you actually give
them access how does that work with
in-app purchases like say you're buying
some gold coins to get to the next level
and then you're not connected and then
you're like oh I got to Mexico there's a
lot of code you have to do - yeah well
you got simplified in d3 writing this
yeah d3 helps a lot with that
it is synchronous and the Play Store
does catch the transactions so basically
if it doesn't succeed just own it
hopefully it's an education yeah or the
users that aren't online understand why
they can't do something okay anything
else come in yes and you join us oh yeah
anybody else in the Hangout have a
question all my text views used SP one
user asked for text size options what
exactly this heater she want
isn't there an option in the settings to
change the font size
and this is from Catalan I think um so
yeah generally the whole point of SP is
so that it acknowledges the system-wide
kind of text size preference
chances are the uses used an app where
the app itself actually has additional
text sizes as in say I want to increase
the size large medium or small and that
could be related to the system font size
as well so I might and that's what it
kind of asking for yeah it's probably
see it in like news reading apps and so
now that they'll quite commonly have a
text size option that you bump it up a
little bit if you like it so I guess
that's what the users are requesting so
yeah beyond so you could say hey go to
settings and change this setting if they
don't to change the font size of their
entire device and they just want to
change it your application
that's fair enough I could understand
why especially if you've chosen
essentially small fonts yeah there are
two options so think about yeah we're
going to make sense for your app whether
you think is a common use case deepers
use magnification each other about three
finger tap is cool so now it's not the
shortest rather they did the movie
rational what was it
open garden yeah and I and I I've been
looking for it during the show and they
cut it out of there they're recorded
video I was watching it live okay I've
got the end on that side so yeah so open
garden stopped doing the NFC and they're
just doing the Bluetooth only mmm or
communicating and that's where they open
up a VPN tunnel between all the
different devices and they measure the
output and they share the bandwidth
between them so if another device comes
on and
says it's connected Wi-Fi or if it's
using whatever HSPA or whatever it'll
they'll share bandwidth and go back and
forth if only one has it they'll all do
it and since it's a VPN tunnel it only
looks like it's coming from that device
okay the extra question is just learned
in the moderator is from the Condor
again jaws might not be the right place
but is there an opportunity to do ensure
internships in Europe I'm guessing a
Google as user experience so I don't
think anyone here knows I think if you
go to a little contrast jobs yeah Google
adjusters then go to the internship
section I'll have all the details I
don't know where the internships land
but there certainly is use experience in
Android phone in Europe so it's entirely
possible yeah if you know righteous none
of the question in the chat string so I
have one question
if we extend application class sometimes
when we clear the activities from the
stack by pressing the back button and we
then launch the app sometimes the last
instance of the application class is
still there but the application object
stays alive for as long as the process
alive so it's singleton so yeah there's
not much else to say other than that
really
umm I'd wonder why are you trying to why
this is affecting your app and because
even if the state you're trying to keep
is specific to an activity that you
should be activating an application yeah
so only keep sort of global stuff that's
you don't care the lifetime live really
in application just of like a she is not
constant you can always empty the back
stack yeah I think the question is more
about why sometimes application keeps
alive then why it doesn't so when you
press back and lock but I say what
you're reporting is expected behavior
but yeah it's probably that it doesn't
work as you imagine it works BEC isn't
closed from McKee's it's always the same
problem when you when you talk to
Android developer starting the
difference between the home and the back
button in
I think the activity is close when you
put back or home you have to watch the
video when you download the apk yeah of
the lifecycle
I was just asking like if if have a
stack of activities and I've convinced
me to press it back when all the
equities from the stack and where all
the activities are cleared my
application gets closed and then I
realize the application the instance of
my last instance of application class is
still there I mean like when I come back
all the values which is like radius link
to the application object are still
there that's right that's correct yeah
expected okay that's expected behavior
yeah that's so that the when you launch
the app again it's in the cache it'll
it's faster next time isn't it correct
yeah I know it'll do those things to try
and keep and activities and applications
around and kill them when it's got
memory pressures yeah so if you actually
need to force those brownies to reset
just grab them on pause or somewhere
further down the lifecycle and reset
yourself
oh yeah has joined us apparently oh yeah
well this this hangout was going to
finish 20 minutes ago because you've run
out of questions but then it just kept
on you've got so much good stuff to
share how can it stop just a quick
question format anymote protocol is that
open sourced
so we've open sourced the libraries are
easy for Android you can also find it in
the since there's a library for this
also just a plain Java library that come
over who did it I'll dig it out for you
but there's an anime library which is
just purely Java doesn't realize
on any Android side of things the actual
Google TV implementation I don't think
is open sourced I think that's kept
in-house so yeah I think it's only the
actual use the protocol is open source
okay cool I think you guys get your
google cups of coffee now god I love
that coffee all right
oh what's that
how Linden saying he had an Ouya demo
room at the Melbourne Android developer
meet up tonight thanks Alan that's funny
cuz he's another one tonight already
happened what are the drawbacks of using
common fake changes orientation on
activity to prevent it from recreating
after screen orientation change only one
I found is that I cannot use different
layout for landscapes you can you can
call request layout anyway so it's not
gonna automatically process it for you
but you can do but it's also to do the
app action bar so the action bar has got
optimizations in landscape where it goes
slightly smaller which we're not
actually have to make you override the
configuration and if you look I don't
know what I think you so we certainly
see video apps or things working this
way that they have the video playing and
you said you don't to restart the video
or interrupt the video when you rotate
it so I'll do the orientation change
themselves and then request layout but
keep the video claims
okay also depends on what your logic is
can you know if you're depending on
getting your on pause and then on resume
call to like you know manage your
state's up retain configuration States
calls is deprecated now
so really rolana okay
we're gonna go for the button when the
broadcast there's nothing else coming in
no what a shame from here on let me go
every time you read my profession and
everybody take a shot that's ten shots
today all right cheers guys thanks for
joining us thank you
did I go live